throughout his career M night Shyamalan
has managed to carve out a distinct
filmography filled with stylized genre
efforts featuring compelling characters
extraordinary mysteries and some of the
greatest twists in the history of cinema
here are all of em night Shyamalan
movies ranked from worst to best M night
Shyamalan built his reputation on
crafting thoughtful blockbuster films
with non blockbuster budgets of his
first seven films none cost more than 75
million dollars to make so it was a
little surprising that on the heels of
two major flops Shyamalan managed to
procure a whopping 150 million dollars
for his adaptation of the fantastical
adventure The Last Airbender maybe he
just couldn't resist the temptation to
go bigger than he'd ever gone before but
those who bought a ticket to see The
Last Airbender were left wondering
exactly where that money went
a wave of abysmal reviews greeted the
movie's release considering that
airbender is based on a wildly inventive
nickelodeon series you've got a marvel
at the sheer dullness of this adaptation
which is driven by soulless performances
stale visuals uninspired set pieces and
unbelievably bad special effects
needless to say initial plans for a
Shyamalan directed Airbender trilogy
were promptly halted though the film
still fared reasonably well at the box
office
in fact it managed to rake in north of
300 million dollars worldwide which may
be the biggest twist Shyamalan has ever
pulled prior to beginning production on
his 2006 fairy tale lady in the water
Shyamalan was on one hell of a winning
streak with two instant classics to his
credit in a couple of solid box-office
hits to boot so lady in the water which
boasted a cast fronted by Paul Giamatti
Bryce Dallas Howard and Jeffrey Wright
made its premiere aiming for a higher
bar than even Shyamalan might have
understood
needless to say critics were less than
kind to Shyamalan bonkers the yarn about
a blue-collar guy trying to help a
stranded water fairy return to her home
world the sadly it's hard to disagree
with those reviews though lady in the
water features stunning visual elements
the story is a wildly unfocused
confection of kooky characters
half-baked fantasy elements and
contrived plot twists lady in the water
sunk with audiences to becoming Shah
Milan's first legit box-office bomb and
one of his most disappointing efforts to
date Shyamalan began to work on his
debut film praying with anger while
still a student at NYU he wrote produced
funded directed and starred in the
project himself it revolves around an
Americanized young man of East Indian
descent returning home to rediscover his
roots and Shyamalan who was born in
India and raised in an affluent suburb
of Philadelphia based praying with anger
on his own return trip to India and his
teens needless to say it was an
intensely personal story praying with
anger has a warmth and sense of humor
all but absent from much of his later
work as with most debuts however it
isn't without its problems the movie
suffers from tone and pacing issues in
Shyamalan never a particularly strong
performer proves he likely took on one
job too many by casting himself in the
lead whether he made that decision based
on necessity or on hubris Shyamalan
Splatt detached performance is often
painful to watch I just decided I want
to see as much
Vindhya as i can there are a lot of
beautiful things in this culture really
beautiful luckily there's enough going
on beneath the surface of praying with
anger to keep it engaging at the very
least it's a compelling look at a first
time director figuring out just how
movies work even after the costly
debacle that was 2010's The Last
Airbender Shyamalan wasn't quite done
swinging for the big-budget fences and
Hollywood studios weren't quite done
betting big on the director either
Columbia Pictures Pony DUP 130 million
dollars for shyamalan sci fi
adventurer's and although the reviews
weren't quite as abysmal as they had
been for most of his recent efforts they
weren't exactly good that's not totally
surprising after earth was originally
pitched to Shyamalan by Will Smith as a
star vehicle for himself and his sudden
Jaden and follows the pair's they
struggle for survival after being
shipwrecked on an alien planet it's a
promising set up for the Shyamalan
treatment but the surprising lack of
chemistry between the real-life father
and son leaves an emotional void that
the movie struggles to overcome for his
part Shyamalan once again drops the ball
when it comes to the film staging and
visual elements wasting the talents of
brilliant cinematographer Peters who
shitski
along the way though after earth bombed
hard stateside it did well enough
overseas to turn a modest profit still
given his track record with tentpole
fare we're betting it'll be a while
before Shyamalan goes this big again
after giving his fan base cause for
concern with Lady in the water
Shyamalan continued his stumble with the
happening a sci-fi thriller that follows
a teacher his wife and their friends as
they try to outrun a mysterious plague
on paper the concept has the makings of
another intriguing Twilight Zone ish
tail for Shyamalan but the film features
career worst performances from Mark
Wahlberg and Zooey Deschanel a third act
that can only be described as
mind-boggling ly stupid and the sort of
hackneyed tin eared writing that leaves
one wondering how the happening got off
the ground at all my name is Elliott
Moore just going to talk in a very
positive manner giving off good vibes
and there's a reason why this movie
feels unpolished Shyamalan was working
on the script while the 2007 writers
strike loomed over Hollywood fearing a
lengthy content drought Studios began
fast-tracking productions to fill a
potential void and the happen
was one of them it was released to some
of the worst reviews of Shah Millan's
career but the one thing it has got
going for it is a campy irreverent
b-movie charm that never quite lets you
take the on screen absurdity too
seriously that b-movie feel may not be
intentional but it's the only reason
that happening is it all watchable and
ultimately keeps it from claiming the
title of worst Shyamalan movie why you
iron my lemon drink in 1998 Shyamalan
returned to the director's chair for his
family-friendly dramedy wide awake the
plot follows a 5th grader who sets out
on a search for God after the death of
his grandfather though wide awake never
quite hits home straight too often into
the realms of shameless schmaltz it more
than proved the directors skill at
tackling complex dramatic content in a
clever and insightful way as well as his
ability to coax convincing performances
from his cast Shaw Milan's ability to
work with younger actors in particular
would prove important for his next movie
it's hard to believe how many years have
passed since Shyamalan turned the
superhero genre on its head with his
gloriously grounded origin story
unbreakable and it's still surprising
how sneakily nights shocked the world by
connecting his unhinged thriller split
into the same cinematic universe yet
here we are bearing witness to the
rarest of big-screen events a comic book
centric crossover based on wholly
original heroes and villains folks going
into glass expecting a heroes vs.
villains Throwdown on the level of the
latest Marvel confection will be
seriously underwhelmed by the
meticulously paced action unfolding
before them but those expecting a
super-powered psychological thriller
akin to unbreakable and split will find
themselves right at home amongst glasses
morally twisted tale of good and evil
the movie's ambition ultimately Trump's
its quality mostly thanks to some spotty
writing by Shyamalan himself but it also
takes more risks has more fun and
features higher stakes than any film
spawned by the MCU science might be
overly long but it's as close to a
sci-fi masterpiece as anything Shyamalan
has ever delivered it also finds the
director skillfully blending his
penchant for spellbinding mysteries and
paranoia drenched narratives with his
go-to themes of families and strife and
crises of faith all to tell an alien
invasion story with multiple twists this
tale of a fallen preacher struggling
with his faith as a
largely unseen alien menace threatens to
rip his family apart as taut tense
heartfelt and harrowing its bolstered by
one of Mel Gibson's finest performances
not to mention a scene-stealing turn
from Joaquin Phoenix for much of its
runtime sines is a near-flawless blend
of horror tinged atmospherics classic
alien invasion tropes and tragic
religious parable that's unafraid to
wear its heart or its influences on its
sleeve if only the final 10 minutes of
the movie didn't exist it might have had
a legit claim to the top spot on this
list sadly that ending does exist and if
you've seen it you probably know why
science doesn't even earn a place in the
top 5 the village might be the most
underrated film in Shaa Milan's big bag
of movies
yes it's central conceit is shamelessly
manipulative yes the film's big twists
are underwhelming and obvious but while
those issues are impossible to ignore
they're not really the point they exist
Moors fanservice genre fodder and
structural plot devices than focal
points of the actual story that story
happens to be one of Shyamalan best
it's a mournful and gothic chamber piece
bent on exploring the weighty
correlation between grief and fear
presented in the guise of a straight-up
horror tail the plot finds an isolated
village on edge when the mystical
creatures who dwell in the surrounding
woods appear to break the terms of a
long-standing treaty Shyamalan wisely
focuses on interpersonal drama allowing
Roger Deakins Stark expressive
photography and James Newton Howard
dolefully romantic score to bestow the
village within a motive yet disquieting
unease in the process he tells one of
his most patently human stories one
that's well worth revisiting
after reeling off his fourth straight
big-budget misfire and after earth even
Shyamalan seemed to think a break was in
order
fortunately for film lovers everywhere
he used his brief downtime to recharge
his imagination and refine his cinematic
approach when he returned with 2015
pseudo found-footage thriller the visit
he proved he was ready to reclaim the
title of genre maestro the visit is
every bit the lean focused genre jumping
mood fest we've come to expect from
Shyamalan surly work
only this story which is centered on
teenage siblings visiting their
grandparents and finding them entrenched
in some seriously strange behavior feels
a little different
it's dangerous and even a little
depraved in ways we hadn't really seen
from Shyamalan before the visit feels
like Shyamalan finally giving over to
the paranoid claustrophobic menace he'd
only touched upon in his prior films
while the movies handheld vantage points
only heightened the broiling anxiety
underneath that unexpected mix of
anxiousness and dark danger heralded the
second coming of a filmmaker who'd found
a way to tweak his signature style to
feel as energetic and exhilarating as it
did in the beginning the visit didn't
quite put Shyamalan back on top but it
proved he was finally back in the game
armed with an edgy new approach and
backing from a risk-taking studio in
Blum House Shyamalan was about to get
down and dirty with a new genre medley
it would turn out to be one of the
wildest creepiest rides of his career
[Music]
packed with more twists than any
previous shamah on film and anchored by
an eerily transfixing performance from
James McAvoy split follows the
nightmarish tale of a man with multiple
personality disorder as he struggles to
find balance in his fractured mind a
dangerous new personality threatens to
take control and force him to do
unspeakable things it's a brilliant
blend of psychological thriller and
straight-up horror and it shyamalan one
of the best reviews and box office
returns of his career
all while unexpectedly leading into a
belated sequel of one of his most widely
acclaimed films unbreakable arrived in
theaters in the fall of 2000 behind a
cryptic trailer and under a thick shroud
of secrecy over the years it has
proceeded to blow the minds of pretty
much everyone who's ever seen it there's
really not much to say about unbreakable
that hasn't already been said except
that it's one of those rare films that
remains consistently re watchable even
after you've uncovered all of its
secrets that the film contains what may
well stand his career best work from
bruce willis and samuel l.jackson is a
big reason for the film's success but
unbreakable stylish ly muted hyper
realistic approach to the superhero
origin story is a larger part of why it
remains one of the brighter highlights
in Shyamalan filmography not exactly a
twist ending to this list but
what else could land the top spot no
matter how many superb movie Shyamalan
might make it will always come back to
his breakout supernatural hit The Sixth
Sense
twist ending aside perhaps the most
surprising thing about The Sixth Sense
is that it was released only about a
year after his soso family dramedy wide
awake
it seems that all Shyamalan needed to
find his groove was a couple of ghosts
and one terrified ten-year-old the Six
Senses tale of a kind-hearted boy who
sees dead people found the director
working with a new level of confidence
it also found him coaxing a career
redefining performance out of Bruce
Willis and one of the greatest child
performances in history from a young
Haley Joel Osment yes that twist is the
stuff of legend but the story still
works even when you already know what's
coming perhaps what sets Shyamalan
supernatural puzzlebox apart from the
pack is that no matter how many times
you watch it the sixth sense always
seems to offer something new to discover
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]